for 18 years hello everyone i'm lana
condor and i'm cole sprouse and we are
here with buzzfeed to take the co-star
test let us begin
okay
[Music]
their birthday um you're you're a
tourist and here's someone that knows
zodiac in here what what month is the
taurus may ah nice okay someone who
knows zodiac oh hold on i'm still here
you're all leo i'm gonna say may 9th
no but very close
okay well what's mine yours so he said
august or july
you
wait we shot moonshot
oh oh oh oh july
july
i remember i remember because i was
invited to the birthday party july
19th
i mean so wrong
you couldn't be more wrong
august 4th
really yes oh and what's yours um may
11th oh see so i'm going to check that
off from me their middle name
i'm going to go with like us like i feel
like you're a middle name do do i know
you should i should actually i don't
know i don't know well you should
because you're supposed to be my friend
benjamin
benjamin you got a baby do i strike you
as a benjamin yeah
yeah
yeah oh i remember you telling me yours
well i think i told you because you like
pestered me
for hours on set huh
do you want a hint no why would i give
you a hint do you want a hint yeah i do
want to hit okay it starts with m mateo
wait wait he's italian matteo
matthew
matthew that's my dad's name mark
no you can't just go through the whole
list guess mine well give me the first
letter t
theresa
therese okay so you should you should
get that what is your middle name
mitchell
i said mateo i got eyes first time we
met
that would be the shoot that would be
the shoot ooh their coffee order uh
black yep uh yours is a
caramel macchiato frappuccino with a
little extra
whip oh
no uh oat milk latte yeah their favorite
rom-com forgetting sarah marshall uh-huh
which one did you say four questions
there's a number in it
37 christmases
failure to launch
no
how to lose a guy in 10 days you don't
get that okay their favorite project of
yours my favorite project of yours is
moonshot
likewise
coming out
at the end of march their beliefs on
extraterrestrial life i believe you
believe yes i believe
favorite snack from crafty now this is a
complicated question because every
crafty is very different oh but let's
say from our crafty okay
i kind of feel
like we're more meal people i mean i was
snacking and you were snacking i wasn't
snacky snacking no but you're more of
like a meal
anthony
anthony well tell me what yours is
uh my favorite snack at crafty is like
those um
um like the snot oh the snyder's like
well yes nori but the um honey mustard
pretzels oh yes
the last project they worked on before
moonshot
oh what was the last thing you worked on
before moonshot uh
wait yeah riverdale yeah but that come
on
well i get it for 18 years all the boys
yeah all the boys three well thank you
about that yeah their dressing room must
have their dressing room must-have
and
yes
wow and for you ooh ooh your computer
sure their giveaway that they're about
to break character
i mean that face
yeah there's this thing that you do
where you go
just like quiver but then i get mad at
myself you know your thing you don't
really break character you get he gets a
glint in his eyes that hear that
annoyingly only enhances his performance
yeah
but i break it's called existential
dread
and if you let it sort of sit
on the forefront of your consciousness
all day long you never break
their go-to activity between filming
scenes sleep i mean you were napping on
the floor literally all the time
and yours i think like
you
go too i record you sleeping recording
recording me sleeping you like
played video games yeah you know for
sure the favorite scene that you shot
together like the most fun we had
shooting a scene or like the best scene
i mean they were all like we had a lot
of fun consistently i know yours
it was that cafe scene before we took
off on the spaceship and
you were all sad
and then i kept doing this really sad
walk away oh my well you had a sad walk
away throughout yeah was yours the
spacewalk
no cause we were resting on our stomachs
for an hour
my favorite scene of the two of us um
drunk sophie maybe that was fun uh i
really like when we were in the hallway
for the first time and you see me
smacking on that oh yeah yeah yeah that
was great
they're hidden tables
i mean i can do the robot voice which we
almost implemented into the movie really
yeah well what's my hidden talent
you can do a backflip standing up watch
this is crazy
i can't i don't know you don't i don't
really have a hidden talent no most of
my talents i
yeah you sell i sell it
i feel you
[Laughter]
i got 12 out of 15. i got 8 out of 15.
that's on brandt you know a lot about
your co-star you have become friends and
know all of the basics and then some you
can't wait to become even closer because
the years go on
every year yeah i got more than you but
i got the same answer which i think is
unfair this is sweet because i clearly
know more
about my co-star
google is free you think i go home and
i'm like this is what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna google cole sprouse doesn't
everybody
[Music]